It's one thing to be lauded as being at the
top of your profession, but it's a different
sort of mind that belongs to someone who just
quits for a while, because they think they've
already solved all the problems and answered
all the discussions in their field.
That's exactly what Ludwig Wittgenstein did
after he published his Tractatus Logico-Philosophicus
in 1922.
It would be the only book he'd publish in
his lifetime, and with it, he was convinced
that he'd finished the discussion about philosophy.
So, he did what anyone would do after they've
finished: they quit.
His hiatus wouldn't last long, but it's a
fascinating glimpse into the man who would
be remembered as one of the 20th century's
greatest philosophers.
He was a self-loathing genius, a man born
into wealth and the aristocracy, a man who
knew all too well what it was like to have
everything taken away in the blink of an eye.
He gave away a huge amount of money, fought
and lived through World Wars, saw the darkest
side of human nature — and through it all,
he struggled to make sense of it.
He may not have solved all the problems of
philosophy, but he definitely gave the world
something to think about.
Did he create Hitler and the Third Reich?
Ludwig Wittgenstein was the youngest of a
very wealthy family, but that's not to say
that he belonged to old money.
His father, Karl, was the son of a wool merchant,
and spent his early life much like the rest
of us — rebelling against his own father's
wishes and working some strange, odd jobs
before finally falling into where he needed
to be.
At one point, he even headed to the US with
nothing but a violin, hoping to make a living
as an entertainer.
Unfortunately for the young Karl, the assassination
of President Abraham Lincoln put a hold on
all forms of public entertainment, and he
was forced to find work as a barkeeper and
a teacher.
He eventually returned to his home in Vienna,
was reconciled with his parents, and was hired
to work as a draftsman on the construction
of a steel mill.
His elders had their doubts, but he was "extraordinarily
able and industrious," and he impressed them
even further when he developed a knack for
sourcing steel and iron during a period of
economic crisis.
It wasn't long before he was making investments,
profiting from the growth of the rails, and
finally making a fortune off the 1878 war
between Russia and Turkey.
By the time Ludwig Wittgenstein was born in
1889, his family had money and influence.
They moved through all the social circles
of the upper echelons of Vienna's cultural
and intellectual crowds, and their wealth
only continued to grow at a rate that allowed
Karl to retire in 1898, at the age of 51.
Theirs was a life of leisure; they amassed
collections of art and manuscripts, furniture
and porcelain.
And Karl's siblings — all 11 of them — were
just as successful.
It was a family of scientists and soldiers,
of great thinkers, of judges, of patrons of
the arts, and doctors.
The Wittgenstein home was a hustle and bustle
of Viennese culture, and Karl's children grew
up in a home frequented by the likes of Sigmund
Freud, Johannes Brahms, and Karl Kraus.
It's also during this time that Wittgenstein
read one of the books that would have a lifelong
impact on him: Otto Weininger's 1903 book
Sex and Character.
While it's still debated just how much of
an impact the book had, it is generally credited
for introducing Wittgenstein to the idea that
life should be lived in an almost single-minded
pursuit of the creation of a work of pure
genius.
Lofty aspirations, for sure, but hearing some
of the names he grew up around, it's easy
to see why he would be so determined to achieve
greatness and immortality through his work.
But that good fortune that shaped Karl's generation
did not extend to the next.
Our Wittgenstein would leave the family home
for Cambridge in 1911, and by then, he had
already lived through the deaths of several
siblings.
His oldest brother, Hans, headed off to America
and disappeared in 1902 — the family believed
he took his own life.
In 1904, the second oldest, Rudy, did the
same by drinking a glass of potassium cyanide.
As a way of coping, Karl forbid the rest of
the family from ever mentioning either of
their names again, and it was an order that
didn't just push an already devastated family
to the breaking point, it broke them.
The relationship between the remaining children
and their parents was never the same, and
it explained quite a bit about what would
happen later.
Even as a young Ludwig Wittgenstein suffered
through the loss of his brothers, it's worth
taking a slight aside here to address one
of those rumors that sounds so unlikely, so
strange, that it has to be false.
And in this case… it's only partially false.
Historians and scholars have long tried to
figure out just what drove Hitler's anti-Semetic
madness, and there's a single mention in Mein
Kampf that goes like this: "I did meet one
Jewish boy who was treated by all of us with
caution, but only because various experiences
had led us to doubt his discretion and we
did not particularly trust him…"
That's led to a lot of speculation that Wittgenstein
was that boy, as he and Adolf Hitler did — albeit
briefly — attend the same school in Linz.
It was the 1904-1905 school year, and it's
a rewarding theory.
Not only would both go on to be written about
in the history books, but it would help make
sense of one of the biggest questions of the
Holocaust: Why?
Wittenstein and his family would feel the
icy grip of the hand of the Third Reich, but
that's for a bit later in the tale.
The first strike against this story that Wittgenstein
inspired Hitler's rabid hatred of the Jews
is that for three generations, the Wittgensteins
had been practicing Roman Catholics, and he
didn't necessarily identify as Jewish — even
though baptismal records identified three
of his four grandparents as being Jewish before
their conversion.
And that, too, is going to become important.
And there's an end to that quote that often
gets omitted from the conspiracy theories:
"... but neither I nor the others had any
thoughts on the matter."
It's generally believed that it wasn't until
much later that Hitler's anti-Semetism kicked
into high gear, and it's worth noting that
mainstream history has pretty much cleared
Wittgenstein of being the root cause of Hitler's
anti-Semetism.
"I shall certainly encourage him.
Perhaps he will do great things…"
Wittgenstein's education was as erratic as
his father's young life had been.
He didn't start in philosophy, in fact, he
started out about as far from philosophy as
possible.
After studying mechanical engineering in Berlin,
he switched to aeronautics — and particularly
the study of kites — in 1908.
That's also when he headed off to Manchester
in England, and his work there led him down
the road to mathematics.
Finding himself pondering heavy philosophical
musings over the foundations of mathematics
as a whole, he sought out the mathematician
and philosopher Gottlob Frege.
It was Frege who recommended that he speak
with Bertrand Russell, and it was Russell
who saw the potential for "great things" in
the young student.
Wittgenstein saw the potential for great things
in himself, too, once asking Russell, "will
you please tell me whether I am a complete
idiot or not?"
When Russell asked him why, he responded with,
"Because, if I am a complete idiot, I shall
become an aeronaut; but, if not, I shall become
a philosopher."
Russell instructed him to write a bit of philosophical
argument, and he did.
Russell read just a single sentence and told
him, "No, you must not become an aeronaut."
Wittgenstein only spent a few years at Cambridge,
and a year after meeting Russell, he had spent
so much time and effort in the pursuit of
logic that Russell declared there was nothing
more to teach him.
He said, too, that he was difficult — he
would often show up in his mentor's rooms
in the middle of the night, pace relentlessly,
and declare that when he left, he was going
to kill himself.
Russell wouldn't send him away, and they would
sit in silence for hours.
Finally, Russell asked him if he was pondering
the mysteries of logic or of his sins, and
responded simply, "Both."
And he took his deep thoughts very seriously,
heading off to Norway for months at a time
to simply think without the distractions of
campus life.
He built himself a wooden hut at the edge
of a fjord, and it was there that he laid
the groundwork for his beliefs that facts
can be shared through what he called "logical
forms".
Wittgenstein left Cambridge in 1913 and it
was a year marked by the passing of his father.
He quickly gave away his inheritance and by
this time, it was the eve of World War One.
The following year he voluntarily enlisted
in the Austrian Army, and far from being scared,
his writing suggests he was looking forward
to the war and to the opportunity of getting
up close and personal with death.
He wrote in one journal "only death gives
life its meaning," and at first, he did spend
quite a bit of the war well out of harm's
way.
When it came time for him to volunteer for
a posting, though, he chose one of the most
dangerous: he headed out into no man's land,
and manned a lookout post at the front of
the Austrian line.
Throughout the war, Wittgenstein continued
to write both philosophy and to those he had
met and studied with at Cambridge.
His admiration of Russell — and Russell's
appreciation of his intellect — perhaps
predictably began to go downhill.
He was as difficult as he was brilliant, their
relationship turned into one of bickering,
and a regular theme in Wittgenstein's journals
was one of lament.
He was heartbroken at the responses he was
getting from his fellow philosophers: even
if he survived the war, he wrote, he wondered
about the usefulness of his work and worried
that no one would understand it — or be
able to grasp how important it was.
He wrote constantly during the war, compiling
notes for what would eventually be turned
into his Tractatus Logico-Philosopicus — or,
in translation, his Logical-Philosophical
Treatise.
It would be the only book he would publish
in his lifetime, and scholars that look back
over the work in context of what he was going
through at the time say it was undoubtedly
influenced by the war, and shaped by both
his time in relative safety behind the front
lines, and in the thick of the fighting.
It was at this time, too, that he read Tolstoy's
The Gospel in Brief, and had something of
an epiphany.
He read it again and again as wrote his own
works on logic, work that was eventually led
in the direction of combining ethics, religion,
and aesthetics with logic.
At the heart of the matter was that all of
those topics couldn't be satisfactorily explained
with words, they needed to be shown.
Confusing?
Absolutely, and he said so himself when he
wrote a friend with this insight: "If only
you do not try to utter what is unutterable,
then nothing gets lost.
But the unutterable will be — unutterably
— contained in what has been uttered."
And that sums up how difficult Wittgenstein
can be to read, much less understand.
In 1918, he was captured, and spent the remainder
of the war in an Italian POW camp; here, too,
he kept writing, and when he was released,
he published his seminal work.
Summing it up briefly is just impossible,
but it's worth nothing that not only did Bertrand
Russell write the original introduction for
it, but Wittgenstein was fairly disgusted
with what he thought was a complete misunderstanding
of the text.
At the heart of it is the idea that the world
consists of objects.
In turn, combinations of objects result in
what he described as a state of affairs, and
facts were ultimately states of affairs that
existed in the real world, and could be described
via those objects.
Basically.
Wittgenstein had a reason for exploring all
of this, and he was trying to construct a
system that would allow for a framework with
which to divide the world into two areas:
"sense and nonsense."
Interestingly, some of the things he defined
as "senseless" under his system were things
like mathematics and logic, while nonsense
was something else completely.
That was the idea that something is completely
devoid of meaning, and well, he had a lot
of time on his hands during the war.
Considering that even the professionals in
the world of philosophy have trouble describing
his work and tracing the leaps and bounds
he makes in his logic, we're just going to
leave this one right here.
And that's exactly what Wittgenstein did,
too.
After the publication of his work, he was
completely convinced that there were simply
no more problems left to solve.
He quit philosophy and took on a less complicated
life, spending nearly a decade traveling around
Vienna, taking on odd jobs from gardening
to architect, and occasionally teaching.
That particular vocation came to an abrupt
and rather brutal end; in one Austrian mountain
village, he struck a student so hard he knocked
the boy unconscious.
His immediate resignation followed, along
with a long bout of depression.
Fortunately for the world of philosophy, he
was ultimately exposed to the philosophical
musings of the Vienna Circle, a group of mathematicians,
scientists, and philosophers who met regularly
through the 1920s.
Thanks to them, he realized that there were
still quite a few problems worthy of his attention.
The dawn of World War Two
The realization that there were bigger, better,
and deeper philosophical problems that remained
unsolved led to Wittgentein's return to Cambridge
in 1929; at the time, he wasn't the most famous
member of his family.
That honor went to his brother, Paul, who
had always had an innate gift for music, and
was known as an outstanding concert pianist.
He, too, was in World War One, and suffered
an injury that should have been devastating:
he lost an arm.
But even as his brother wandered Vienna looking
for a point to his continued existence on
Earth, Paul worked with some of the era's
greatest composers to create music for the
piano that required only a left hand to play.
As the world slowly inched toward yet another
conflict that would engulf the globe, the
Austrian brothers found themselves in perhaps
the best of places they could be: on the outside.
In 1939, Wittgenstein was elected to one of
the top positions in Cambridge professorship,
and it helped give him something of infinite
value: British citizenship.
The timing couldn't have been better.
For years, Hitler had been working on reuniting
Germany and Austria; there was a failed coup,
a treaty with Italy that promised to protect
Austria from German aggression, and even attempts
by Mussolini's Italian troops to interfere
with the annexation.
It happened anyway, and in 1938 Austria was
absorbed into the Third Reich.
That had a devastating impact on the Wittgenstein
family.
Remember, they had been long-practicing Christians
by this time, but what was done in practice
and what was written on paper were, in their
case, two different things.
There was still a record of those three Jewish
grandparents, and conversion or no conversion,
that meant they were still considered Jewish
under the Nuremberg laws dictating racial
purity.
None of them were able to vote or do seemingly
petty actions like sit on a park bench.
For all of the siblings, it was dangerous.
Paul in particular — a musical celebrity
of 1930s Vienna — was deeply troubled.
He was no longer allowed to work in the field
of the arts, and more troubling, he was in
violation of another law: Section 2 of the
Nuremberg Law for Protection of German Blood
and German Honor.
He wasn't married, but he was the father of
two children — and their mother was German.
Had they been a normal, everyday sort of family,
they may have been able to flee without attracting
the attention of the Third Reich.
But they were one of the wealthiest in Europe,
and what followed was a complex bit of legal
and financial maneuvering that really didn't
work out well for anyone.
In 1939, the two surviving Wittengenstein
brothers (brother Kurt had also committed
suicide at the end of World War One) appealed
their case based on the fact that a single
grandparent was the bastard child of a gentile.
Along with the appeal went a significant bribe:
they handed over most of their fortune to
the Nazi regime but in turn, their sisters
Hermine and Helene were granted half-breed
status and were safe from the relentless march
of the Nazi war machine.
It's undeniable that the Wittgenstein fortune
aided the advancement of the Third Reich,
and if there ever was a philosophical question
that needed debate, it's that one.
What was the true price paid for the safety
of the Wittgenstein sisters?
Was it worth it?
Should they have paid, and would you have?
It's a question that can only be answered
by those faced with the impossible question.
It was Paul who was the driving force behind
the decision to transfer much of the family's
fortune from a trust in a Swiss bank account
to the coffers of the Third Reich; he, the
oldest sibling, would be the last to die,
and after he made the decision to save them,
he would never see any of his siblings again.
For his part during the war, Ludwig Wittgenstein
worked as a porter at Guy's Hospital in London…
and here is where we touch on a few of the
things that historians and scholars have never
truly been able to answer.
The mysteries of Wittgenstein
Wittgenstein's writings make it clear that
there are some unresolved issues simmering
away in the background, and it's a fascinating
glimpse into the mind of a man so obsessed
with logic.
For one, it's never quite clear whether or
not he considered himself Jewish.
Occasionally, he did call himself a "Jewish
thinker," while at other times, he condemned
what he believed was a misrepresentation of
his ancestry.
Similarly, Wittgenstein found himself fighting
an almost constant battle with his sexuality.
At the time, it wasn't just taboo to be gay,
it was illegal and would have been met with
outrage and ostracization at the very least.
It's impossible to tell what kind of effect
bearing that sort of burden had on his writing
and his philosophy, but it's also been suggested
that he gravitated toward teachings like Freud's,
who suggested people were universally attracted
to both sexes.
It was an idea that was safely mainstream,
and may have been a comforting bit of modern
thought.
There was another constant and underlying
theme throughout not just Wittgenstein's writings,
but through the diaries and journals of those
who knew him.
He spoke often of his thoughts of suicide,
told those closest to him about his sense
of unrelenting shame and lonliness, and of
the possibility of becoming just another one
of his siblings to take that final step.
His friend David Hume Pisent wrote this heartbreaking
glimpse into his psyche: "... he had suffered
from terrific loneliness for the past nine
years, that he had thought of suicide then,
and that he felt ashamed of never daring to
kill himself [...] he told me that all his
life there had hardly been a day in which
he had not at one time or another thought
of suicide as a possibility."
Wittgenstein did ultimately die young, but
he did not take his own life.
For two decades, he struggled to put together
another book but, always the perfectionist,
he consistently failed in putting together
something that would live up to the vision
of what he believed it should be.
His later works were only published posthumously,
and he didn't live to see the influence he
had on 20th century philosophy.
In 1947, Wittgenstein resigned from his post
at Cambridge.
Much like he had once retreated to the quiet
solitude of the fjords of Norway, he later
did the same and headed off to the remote
wilds of Connemara in Ireland.
The peaceful solitude was not to last.
In 1949, he was diagnosed with prostate cancer,
and by 1951, he knew he didn't have long to
live.
He moved into a home with his doctor, and
died on April 29, 1951.
Reportedly, his last words were, "Tell them
I've had a wonderful life."